[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute was
richtig leckeres ich hatte nämlich Bock
auf Burger aber irgendwie keine Lust so
die Burger Bands einzeln zu machen dann
die Patties und so weiter ich habe
gedacht warum machen wir nicht einfach
so ein Burger Kranz aus einem fluffigen
Hefeteig ich schreibe euch wie immer
alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben hier
unten in der Infobox und starte direkt
mit dem Rezept damit ihr direkt
mitmachen könnt und zwar habe ich hier
ganz normales Mehl Typ 405 da gebe ich
jetzt nicht ganz alles in meine Schüssel
so ein bisschen Mehl kommt an die Seite
einfach damit wir gleich nach Gefühl das
Mehl dazugeben können weil wenn ihr
einmal zu viel Mehl drin habt dann ist
der Teig trocken und dann könnt ihr das
eigentlich fast gar nicht mehr gerade
Bügeln so jetzt schiebe ich hier ein
bisschen was an die Seite damit ich eine
Mulde habe da gebe ich jetzt Milch dazu
die habe ich eine Mikrowelle erwärmt so
38 Grad wäre perfekt für unsere Hefe
auch nicht zu heiß und stirbt die Hefe
ab also heißt 40 42 Grad sollte es nicht
sein und jetzt kommt meine frische Hefe
hier einmal zur lauwarme Milch dazu noch
ein bisschen Zucker braucht die Hefe
nämlich als Nährstoff dann verrühre ich
das kurz hier in der Mulde mit der Gabel
dass das 5 Minuten arbeiten und dann
machen wir weiter
[Musik]
so nach fünf Minuten die Hefe so ein
bisschen schaumig geworden können wir
unser Öl mit dazu geben ich habe jetzt
hier Rapsöl ihr könnt auch
Sonnenblumenöl verwenden da gebe ich
jetzt auch unser Salz dazu nicht am
Anfang zu Hefe mitgeben das verträgt
sich nämlich nicht so gut so und jetzt
fange ich an zu kneten das geht
natürlich auch mit den Händen ich mache
es mir gleich und nehmen die
Küchenmaschine und dann gebt ihr nach
und nach Mehl dazu bis es ein richtig
schöner weicher Teig wird aber ganz zum
Schluss knete ich sowieso immer mal ein
paar Sekunden mit den Händen
[Musik]
so Mehl ist ja auch ein Naturprodukt und
daher braucht ihr an manchen Tagen halt
einfach je nachdem welche Charge ihr
erwischt oder welche Packung braucht ihr
halt einfach auch nicht alles das ist
jetzt das was bei mir übrig geblieben
ist hätte ich das von Anfang an rein
getan weil der Teig richtig trocken und
so ist das schön feucht also da ist
nichts trocken der ist perfekt geworden
und da kann ich jetzt einfach die
gleiche Schüssel was ist denn hier so
einfach zurück in die Schüssel jetzt
nehme ich ein bisschen noch von mir für
unten drunter ein bisschen für oben
drüber Deckel drauf und 45 Minuten gehen
lassen so wir nutzen jetzt aber die
Gehzeit und machen die leckere
Hackfleischfüllung so jetzt machen wir
uns lecker würziges Hackfleisch dafür
ein bisschen Öl in der Pfanne erhitzen
und dann braten wir unser Hackfleisch
krümelig also auf höheren Temperaturen
richtig schön krümelig braten und ich
gebe aber jetzt hier auch schon eine
ordentliche Menge an Tomatenmark dazu
das macht das ganze nochmal so ein
bisschen saftig und wenn ihr das auch
noch mal im Öl vorab anröstet entstehen
richtig schöne Röstaromen anschließend
gebe ich das Fleisch dazu und dann gebe
ich nur noch Salz Pfeffer edelsüßes
Paprikapulver und ein bisschen
Kreuzkümmel dazu und dann hat man
einfach schon lecker perfekt gewürztes
Hackfleisch
[Musik]
so Fleisch ist schon mal fertig super
saftig geworden das ging jetzt auch
wirklich ruckzuck und jetzt machen wir
unsere Burger Soße dafür werden einfach
nur ein paar Zutaten zusammen verrührt
also eigentlich ein echt einfaches
Rezept auch wenn das Endergebnis so
super wahnsinnig aufwendig aussieht
könnt ihr meinen Gästen erzählen und
sagen oh das war ein richtiger Aufwand
für euch so Ketchup und Mayo nehmen wir
jetzt hier einfach schon mal als Basis
dann würzen wir das mit ein bisschen
Salz und Paprika edelsüß Knoblauch darf
nicht fehlen und ich gebe noch rote
Zwiebeln mit dazu
[Musik]
so unsere burgersoße ist fertig und es
ist so gewollt dass durch die vielen
Zwiebeln das ganze auch so ein bisschen
dicker wird denn wir machen ja kein
klassischen Burger und belegen das
sondern das wird ja gleich auf dem
Hefeteig verteilt und aufgeräumt und
dann noch mal gebacken deswegen sollte
das schon so ein bisschen also nicht
ganz so flüssig sein sondern so ein
bisschen fester sage ich mal das haben
wir hier noch saubere Gurken für mich
gehören immer saure Gurken auf einen
Burger ich finde das so lecker und was
ist bei euch so mögt ihr da am liebsten
zum Beispiel Tomaten ich bin jetzt nicht
so der Tomaten Fan auf Burgern oder was
was ist so euer Geheimtipp haut mal raus
denn ich kann mir immer mal wieder so
ein bisschen Inspiration von euch klauen
so die werde ich jetzt auch noch mal
ganz grob würfeln und dann können wir
schon weitermachen mit dem Hefeteig der
wird nämlich schön ausgebreitet
[Musik]
so den Teig habe ich auf circa 24 x 30
cm ausgeweitet also schön rechteckig ihr
müsst euch nicht eins zu eins an die
Angaben halten also sollte schon relativ
dünn ausgebreitet werden ich hatte jetzt
hier 6 mm ungefähr nur zur Orientierung
so und jetzt verteilen wir und zwar
erstmal unsere Burger Soße mit den
leckeren Zwiebeln ganz grob und ihr
könnt auch oben ein Zentimeter ungefähr
freilassen dann nehmen wir das gleich
aufräumen drücken wir ja die ganze
Füllung nach vorne und so könnt ihr dann
vermeiden dass ihr euch zu viel Füllung
da raus äh ja dass da so viel rausquillt
einfach ein oder anderthalb Zentimeter
frei lassen im oberen Rand genau da gebe
ich dann gleich mein Hackfleisch drüber
dann die Gewürzgurken und dann wird
alles aufgerollt dann gebe ich darüber
meinen Hackfleisch dann die Gewürzgurken
und dann was nie fehlen darf Käse ganz
viel Käse und dann wird das Ganze
aufgeräumt
[Musik]
so das Aufrollen geht echt easy ich habe
die Seiten jetzt so ein bisschen noch
zusammen gemacht und jetzt kommt es auf
unser Backblech da habe ich schon
Backpapier obendrauf zack einmal hier
drauf kippen so und jetzt brauchen wir
noch was an der Optik denn ich will ja
dass man sieht was es ist und zwar nicht
nur wenn man es anschneidet sondern
direkt und zwar wir fahren jetzt nicht
anders komplett zu halbieren sondern
hier oben da habe ich jetzt zugemacht
kann das ruhig noch so ungefähr 3 cm zu
bleiben dann macht ihr so ein Schnitt
einmal durch die Mitte bis ganz unten
und dann zwiebelt ihr das einfach
ineinander und macht es am anderen Ende
wieder so ein bisschen zusammen und dann
habt ihr eine richtig coole Optik
[Musik]
so den Backofen habe ich vorgeheizt auf
180 Grad Ober und Unterhitze das
Schieben war das ganze jetzt rein und
dann braucht es so 26 bis 28 Minuten bis
der Hefeteig gar gebacken und schön
goldbraun ist
[Musik]
also ich muss schon sagen ich finde das
echt cool dass so mehrere Leute dieses
Burger Feeling haben ich habe gerade
schon probiert als wir die entziehen und
Fotos gemacht haben aber man hat nicht
diesen wahnsinnigen Aufwand ich liebst
du auch Burger selbst zu machen mit dem
Band zum Patties und so weiter aber das
ist überhaupt nicht aufwendig und ihr
bekommt damit echt viel Leute satt so
ich koste jetzt noch mal für euch
der Teig ist schon sehr saftig muss man
sagen der ist jetzt nicht typisch Burger
Bann aber es passt wieder rum zu der
unfassbar saftigen Hackfleischfüllung
und diese Augen gucken sieht mein
Highlight weil das ist trotz dass wir
das gebacken haben immer noch so ein
kleiner Knack und das finde ich mega und
die burgersoße passt natürlich auch
perfekt ihr könnt natürlich auch
burgersoße ohne die Zwiebel noch mal
oben drüber träufeln lassen aber ich
finde so einfach perfekt also ich
wünsche euch jetzt viel Spaß beim
Nachmachen und schreib mir doch gerne
eure liebste Burger Kombination hier
unten rein vielleicht mache ich ja den
nächsten klassisches Burger Rezept und
dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten
Rezept tschüss
[Musik]